pete before i let you go now that you
are uh bitcoin focused you got a price
prediction for the end of the year you
said six figures in there what do you
think is gonna happen yeah sure i'll
throw it out there uh i think we're
gonna go above six figures for sure and
i think that that number is gonna be a
lot larger than most bitcoiners think it
is i think my personal prediction is
that uh we're going to go
probably north of north of 300
i would say that
this is based on my personal uh opinion
that
you know one of the things you see in
bitcoin is when it really goes parabolic
uh you know there's no one selling
bitcoin right so what is the bitcoin
price it is a
you know number that essentially and the
market's sort of looking for a price at
which the marginal seller will return so
i view bitcoin tops as sort of social
attacks on bitcoiners right uh so so pop
for me like the top is the moment where
you're like man i have to sell
like i have to sell some bitcoin because
uh you know my brothers are gonna yell
at me some things that happen uh you
know i'm gonna be sleeping on the couch
tonight if i don't sell my bitcoin uh so
you know since most bitcoiners expect a
hundred thousand um i don't think
they're selling at that point right so i
think the bitcoin price is going to have
to continue going up until uh some point
uh at which it convinces enough people
uh to to redistribute their bitcoins
uh so yeah i'm expecting that the peak
this year to be pretty aggressive i'm a
big believer in cyclical bitcoin price
theory and uh
i actually really take the side of
thinking that we want the bitcoin price
to be more cyclical and predictable i
think if bitcoin you know
uh you know this four year cycle kind of
theory if that breaks down then i i
think it may be a little bit less
confident in bitcoin uh than i than i am
right now and do you think that those
long-term holders are just going to hold
it until they're some specific price or
do you think that they eventually just
say hey 300k is nuts this is just keeps
going up at vertical and then i got to
sell it yeah i mean i think that that's
one of the big questions right so i
talked a lot you have dylan leclair a
lot on this uh program he writes the the
deep dive newsletter for bitcoin
magazine and you know we go back and
forth on this a lot right and my
perspective as someone who's been in the
industry for a long time is that
you know
what is the marginal seller if you
really believe that the bitcoin price
you know is defined not by people
acquiring bitcoin but people refusing to
sell uh then in a top situation really
what you have is the re-emergence of the
marginal seller right somewhat someone
has to be selling bitcoin at some point
right otherwise it's just you know
you're you kind of are in a parabolic uh
spot so i think it's to me
at least this is consistent what i've
seen in the past stops is is the
uh previous tops were essentially uh the
price was so high that they had to
convince the long-term hardened bitcoin
hodler to become the marginal seller
right somebody has to provide the market
with bitcoin the bitcoin price is just a
number it's it's looking to kind of coax
demand out of the market and it's going
to go up until some point where
psychologically you know we as long-term
bitcoiners break so i do think it will
be the long-term bitcoiners you know who
who maybe start uh to think that they
can take something off the table right i
think the alternative view is
essentially that oh that's not gonna
happen you know uh no one's ever gonna
sell their bitcoin i don't know i think
the bitcoin price to can go high enough
to convince you to sell
look i when i started writing about
cryptocurrency uh bitcoin was worth
fifty dollars so i think it would go to
twelve hundred dollars no i watched it
go back to two hundred dollars did i
think go to twenty thousand dollars no i
didn't think it would do that ever at
this point my capacity for disbelief and
the bitcoin price is
you know i think at that point it's you
know uh but again i would i would
actually you know argue on the other
side of that i you know i think that
would be a great thing for the industry
like more people will become interested
in bitcoin hopefully but um you know i
would caution like how much we've really
achieved at that point
i uh i love it you you uh you may be
more bullish than uh anyone else who
brought on the show recently oh really
okay who is the number one on your uh on
your price project who has the most
lofty prediction lots of people for like
the next uh having in a million plus um
but probably what was it raul paul i
think actually 400. he said 400 but he
said it not till the end of q1 or q2 of
next year and so
yeah by the end of this year he thinks
200k
all right so you know what i actually
because this is recorded i actually i i
flipped a little bit and i said 300 but
privately i've been saying 500 because
again i think that
the number has to be high enough
to really wow like you got like like i
think again like one of my theories here
is that bitcoin tops are psychological
attacks on bitcoiners uh because again
we're people who were born in the fiat
system right yeah we
are people who are looking at bitcoin
and viewing it in us dollars and i was
talking about my recent article about
you know sort of bitcoin agnostics right
one of the things with the
cryptocurrency industry is that you know
we're sort of looking at all these
dollar symbols and we're trying to
derive some meaning from it i think that
most bitcoiners also are guilty of that
right so i think
you know uh
yeah if bitcoin wants to create a top
it's going to have to convince some of
you know you the never sell bitcoin
bulls to give up some bitcoin so i i
think uh
i am confident in the bitcoin
technology's ability uh to coax sellers
back to the market and i think that that
uh you know the price at which it does
so will will likely be higher than uh we
can pause it currently because you know
it's it's an attack on us
500k bitcoin a lot of people be freaking
out for that one i just want to be top
on your board
no problem